hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well give his nikuman
can ethics book 3 discussion of the
virtue of courage and the opposed vices
of cowardice and rashness which is quite
lengthy and detailed Aristotle tells us
about five other states or conditions
that person could be in then you might
say masquerade as courage and masquerade
not in the sense that the person is
deliberately putting on a show knowing
that they don't have the virtue of
courage they might themselves be in a
dark about that be mistaken about the
nature of courage they may come from a
culture that that has these things mixed
up Aristotle thinks this is quite often
the case and that's why he's pointing
this out to us he wants to distinguish
these conditions which by the way are
not in themselves bad things it's better
to exhibit something like courage and to
exhibit something like cowardice but
he's not saying that these are totally
disconnected but they are not quite the
same thing as genuine courage so you
notice that we've got all five here on
the board and there's two that are K
connected with each other the sanguine
and the person who has experience and
ignorance and the sanguine are also kind
of connected with each other as well the
from the first one that he starts out
with is what we call citizen or
political courage understanding this to
be you have to think about this for a
bit it's not even as if they had
malicious as such we're like all of the
citizenry belong to it if you were a
citizen of a Greek city-state you were
expected to do military service for the
state and remember they lived in a time
period and a culture in which there was
no absolutely centralized Authority they
didn't have nation-states they had
cities and the next city over might go
to war with you so they did it's not
like 200 miles today to their frontier
it might be a matter of you know five
miles or 10 miles orient on it the
greatest distance perhaps in a hundred
miles going from one end to the other so
citizens were expected to fight on the
battlefield and not fight at a distance
with bows and arrows they were expected
to be the hoplites a one for the most
part there's there's a couple exceptions
of course don't don't worry about that
you military history buffs but for the
most part of any of these heavy shields
and Spears and you would go out there
with a bunch of other guys and try to
jam to your spear into the enemy nuts
that's pretty scary because another guys
are going to do the same thing to you
right and you've got a slinger is
slinging you know balls of letting you
or stones you have archers you have all
sorts of horrible things going on so I
can kind of scary to go on the
battlefield so Aristotle here talks
about the kind of courage that is
displayed by citizen soldiers
interestingly remember Aristotle is a
guy who taught the Iliad as a textbook
to alexander the great one of the most
heroic
the theory figures in history here in
the nick of mccain ethics Aristotle says
that those great heroes at Troy like who
like for example who Diana Diana and
Hector I presumably would say the same
thing about it yes yes and Agamemnon and
perhaps even Achilles who Alexander by
the way wanted to be everyone wanted to
be Achilles um that they were not
exhibiting courage in its full of sense
what up well because the citizen soldier
or the person belonging to me you know
Bronze Age culture and going off to war
for their there you know or for their
country or whatever it is motivated
fundamentally by honor and shame not by
the virtue itself not by recognizing
courage itself as a good thing to be
chosen for its own sake but primarily
they don't want that they want to gain
honor they want to gain glory but they
also are motivated by a sense of shame
idols worry about what other people
might might think of them and we
actually see you know some of the some
of the characters and the Iliad washing
n even when they were approached so
Aristotle says this is really close to
courage but it's not quite the same
thing he also had some other interesting
examples too so he says this type of
courage most closely resembles the
courage that I'm describing because it's
prompted by virtue and by the desire for
something noble namely honor and the
wish to avoid the disgrace of being
approached that's not the case for all
the troops and it's also not the case
for all the trips in for example the
Iliad says the courage of troops being
forced into battle by their officers may
be classed as of the same type but the
motivation is different he says they're
inferior in so much as their motive is
not a sense of shame sense of self-worth
and not wanting that to be called into
question
but fear they don't want to incur
penalties and the penalties could be he
talks for example about people digging
trenches behind their troops so that
their troops can't retreat when you're
doing that sort of thing you are not
promoting courage you're actually just
you know motivating the person by fear
and if we think about how courage is
they actually acquire if you take this
out of the battlefield context pushing
somebody constantly into those things
forcing them to undergo compulsion based
on fear is not going to produce genuine
courage so he goes out and he says you
know in these sorts of cases we're
talking about compulsion force being
used upon a person and he concludes by
saying a person ought not to be brave
because they're compelled to be although
that's still a good thing to act bravely
if you're compelled but because courage
itself is no his column is something
fine worthwhile something that we want
to aspire to so that's one sense of
pseudo courage not quite encouraged the
next one is very interesting experience
he says those who are experienced on a
bit on the battlefield and here he's not
thinking of citizen soldiers here he's
thinking about veterans and mercenary
troops the kinds of people who have done
a lot of action and they know more or
less how things go so when they see
something that ordinary people you know
just putting on their armor for the
first time would find rather dismay nor
terrifyingly like yeah that's not a big
deal you know they see all the horsemen
lineup but it's uneven ground and
they're like yeah the horsemen aren't
really going to get to us here we're
going to be fine and so they have
acknowledged like I could hear knowledge
where others are ignorant that's the
advantage that they have they also tend
to be as Aristotle points out skilled at
what they do so you know for example he
says they're skilled in the use of arms
and equipped with the
best ones for attack and defense
literally armed been fighting it I guess
unarmed or trained athletes against
amateurs even an athletic contest it is
not the brave as two are the best
fighters but those who are the strongest
in the best training so you know if you
have let's take with our our modern
warfare you know if you have best
technology and you know you know that
you have good command and control it
might be a lot easier to be brave then
if your belonging to some ragtag
organization that doesn't seem to have
it to act together and your weapons GM
constantly you know it would make sense
to be to fill the greater sense of fear
right now the problem is this isn't real
courage as soon as they face others who
are just as knowledgeable as that and
that advantage goes away now they're not
quite so confident and cocky about
things and it is he points out a little
bit later he says professional soldiers
proof cowards when the danger it poses
too great a strain and when they're in a
disadvantage and numbers and equipment
actually their knowledge turns against
them at that point you know citizen
soldiers might be motivated by a sense
of honor or shame or patriotism and say
we're going to take our stand here and
fight those those imperialistic or
whatever people coming in right we're
going to we're going to do that
professional soldiers are like yeah
we're probably going to get slaughtered
here and I'm not really in it for the
otter you know I think we better get the
hell out of here we better you know pack
up our shields and take a lot so they're
not going to display courage when in
certain respects it's most needed now
that would be the opposite of what
happens with anger and the Greek term
there the reason I put it up there to
begin with is because there's there's
actually two terms that get used pretty
consistently by Aristotle for anger when
is discussing it in terms of virtues and
vices he talks about or gay here are you
talking about cinema
broader and that's also a term that was
used quite a bit in in the Iliad and
earlier literature so what he's talking
about there is he says here we go spirit
or anger right how we want to translate
through Moses class with courage men
emboldened by anger like wild beasts
which rush upon the hunter that has
wounded them are supposed to be
courageous why because the courageous
are also high-spirited is that's the way
we translate thermal thermal edicts that
is you know motivated by by this is dry
this energy this passion the
spiritedness right the prophet and this
can actually lead to some very
courageous seeming action so let's let's
dwell on that bit he says spirit is very
impetuous in encountering danger so
Homer writes he puts strengthen their
spirit and rouse there might in their
spirit and bitter wrath up through his
nostrils weld all these sorts of things
are talking about how people get riled
up they and we can think about this in
terms of off the battlefield we can
think about this in terms of athletics
we can think about this in terms of
going in and taking a hard stand during
that that boardroom meeting that you
have to go to we can think about this in
all sorts of examples confronting a
bully 4441 in all these cases as
Aristotle says the person is
fundamentally motivated by that emotion
by that passion and they're not there
for being motivated by reason or by
principle so it's not courage in a
strict sense it's something that
masquerades is courage and it doesn't
get you quite so far as genuine courage
woof not a bad thing of course he says
this form of courage that is inspired by
spirit seems to be the most natural and
when
it is it's an animal response but when
it is as he says reinforced by
deliberate choice provide races which
will be doing another core concept video
on it can be steered into genuine
courage this can provide the raw
material you might say for genuine
courage but raw material isn't yet the
finished product any more than you know
a binding and some pages and ink is a
book so this is an important one to keep
in mind let's talk about the same with
that this is similar he says to the
people who have experience in this case
it's not so much having knowledge that's
been provided by experience a knowing
that the cavalry won't really be able to
charge across broken ground and it's
more having been unfortunate having had
things work out for you having been
successful people who the word here LP
days literally means those we have good
hopes right and why do they have good
hopes or good expectations because
things have been going good for that so
far they had been fortunate so they can
afford to be sanguine right people
who've been beaten down a lot typically
tens of you know are sanguine and their
knots excess it does not be there you
know there's no connection to reality at
that point or they you know start
becoming much more realistic or even
pessimistic people for whom things go
well typically become quite saying with
they become confident there you go in
the problem is what happens when that no
longer works out there like the
experienced people when things aren't
going their way that seeming courage
which is really just a matter of
confidence rather than courage brings
down up Aristotle also interestingly
says drunk people take this now we might
say it drunk people are also more like
the
that we'll talk about in a moment but if
they consider it people talk you know
these these expressions like Dutch
courage not sure where that came from
I'm sure show minute some people put
that in a comment or a liquid courage we
say more often these days Dutch courage
occurs I know a jack london's story it
called Dutch courage but i'm not sure
where he got it from and he says that
you know this makes the people sang win
for the time being the problem is is
that this can't really be relied upon
the the genuinely brave person is able
to do well is able to act bravely even
when things aren't going their way even
when you know new things arise that they
haven't encountered before let's talk
last about any urance though this is
probably the funniest one and there are
many many cases of people who are quite
bold because they don't realize what
they have gotten themselves into and
then it suddenly works out for them that
if that's the case they could become
sanguine right or I suppose if they
actually realize what was going on they
might become the experience the
ignorance can often be be quite bold
like he says those who face danger and
ignorance appear courageous then they
come very near to those whose bravery
breasts on being sanguine they're
inferior to them again as much as they
lack self-confidence which the sanguine
person possesses when they realize what
is actually going on what is it says
when they've been deceived as to the
danger if they learn or suspect even
suspect the true state of affairs they
suddenly become quite scared and then
they have to back out and then you know
that whatever courage they were
displaying suddenly goes wait we have
lots of movie characters who are like
this it's an interesting plot where
somebody who's who's a ignorant enters
into a situation with a genuinely
dangerous person encounters them
axis as they really aren't dangerous the
townspeople you know we think of
westerns right the townspeople are just
amazed that this person stood up to the
the bully the guy who has been killing
everybody else and the guy who's been
due to have backs down a bit right and
now the person gets really cocky and
then they suddenly find out oh that guy
is a killer wow I almost got killed
myself and then they're faced with with
a quandary right do they in the movies
do they cave in and act like a coward
usually if they do so then there's some
other you know lead there to say hey you
should neck like that right you were
you're not a coward or don't be a coward
let you know grow a pair something we
often say or do they decide that they're
going to exhibit genuine courage if they
do then they're no longer actually from
the basis of ignorance and they be
genuinely courageous usually it makes
for better press and better TV that they
have to be talked into it and then
somewhere along the line they find their
courage but we're getting a little bit
far away from aerosol yeah so we have
five different ways in which a person
can seem to be courageous but not
actually have the virtue of courage